So next game with black against the
King Destroyer from the
USA 24 I've never
played against them so
you usually remember these somewhat Martial names
but I've really never had that before
so D git with bishop F4
we have rook C1 yes it is  She's already played everything a lot of
times here on the
board, well, I always
thought it wouldn't work at all
because of Queen A5, let's see because A2 is
stuck, but
it's a bit slow, of
course, of
course C4
maybe  Just a moment, think about it
now, that wasn't right now,
set the queen or something like that. A1
I still have queen B3
3 B6
h runner C2 then I'll do queen A6 is
a bit dangerous, well, let's see,
yes he has, he already has one
a bit of development no you ca
n't completely
deny that
so well yes
I can't completely believe it
now that that's enough compensation
for white
but well it's a
blitz game if he now evades in the Dausch
with Queen
E2 yes he doesn't evade yes
maybe it's even  not so
sensible, although knight E5
surprises me somehow because I think
it's the wrong way round, so it doesn't matter
swap and bishop E6 that's why
I thought it was the
wrong way round because otherwise bishop E6 was always
a problem because of knight G5 and
maneuvers like that. Visually it's
of course good  on e5 but now I can
comfortably cover the H and
well straight to D8 and B5 and so I do
n't see yet how he's
doing something right here right now so yeah okay
then it comes to C6 yeah okay
I'll first rook rook C8  Play
tower C8
first, so now you can of course
just play bishop D5 and say I'll
give it back to you and have the good
structure at the end.
Let's just play H. Let's
just assume that it's not the best
purely objectively but at least now it's
relative  It's easy to play the
position so white now has the Isolani
on d4 and I just have the nice
blocking jumper. The bishop is
n't exactly nice either. It's
a bit stupid that I'm having
a bit of difficulty
exchanging on the c line.
Yes, I noticed that too  But
I don't think it's that bad
here.
Well, it's not that easy
to get ahead, but
I don't have any. I want to
try now to see if I can do that,
so the idea now is Bishop E7 F6.
King F7 F6 takes the
squares away from the knight like that  Maybe he wants to
go to C4 somehow, but no matter, I have to
do something here so
that the king can
help out a little, so yeah, okay, he's
aiming for the C5 field,
but when I play B6 now
he has some great, some
great story here
B6  I mean, the knight has absolutely
no field, no
zero fields, for example, rook D8, now it's
interesting to find out what he moves,
what does he do now if I
could have taken the game to C1 and then
played it, so well, that's what it was
away no
now A5 to
simplify or knight C7
somehow I still take more
material from the
board time
warning so with the door
C2
Check
t 16 seconds I still have
check
now luckily I also have
matiideas that should be difficult for
him  now
here
Y yes, somehow that still makes a pretty
good impression, no, I don't know
exactly, you probably could have
kept the pawn, but the
nice thing about a position like that is
that it's very comfortable to play.
Here it was somehow like that
However,
that was of course a tough move on
his part. He just has to go back
and continue to let himself be tortured and I think
that thing is gone, I
mean, I don't know how he can get it out now